terminator dark fate features some
familiar faces not just from the beloved
action sci-fi franchise but from other
films and TV shows Linda Hamilton and
Arnold Schwarzenegger are joined by a
few newcomers he had just might
recognize from both the big and small
screens while it may seem difficult to
separate Hamilton from the role of Sarah
Connor badass action icon and
protagonists of the first two Terminator
movies she's had memorable roles both
before and after 1984 as the Terminator
she starred as Vicki in the 1984 horror
film children of the corn and between
1987 and 1990 she starred opposite Ron
Perlman on CBS's Beauty & the Beast
in 1997 she starred with Pierce Brosnan
and Jamie renee Smith in the disaster
thriller hit Dante's Peak she hit the
small screen in a big way in 2010
appearing on two episodes of weeds and
scoring a recurring role on NBC's Chuck
as a CIA agent and Chuck's estranged
mother in recent years she's nabbed a
recurring antagonist spot on Syfy's
defiance and a prominent guest role on
the supernatural drama Lost Girl I'll be
back
the athletic woman we see going
head-to-head with the new Terminator in
the teaser is Grace played by Mackenzie
Davis as of her appearance in dark fate
Davis's professional film acting career
is just under a decade old her first
starring film role came in 2013 with the
romantic drama breathe in she appeared
as miles tellers friend and eventual
love interest in 2014's That awkward
moment
Davis's tireless engineer Mindy Park
played a key role in getting Matt
Damon's astronaut Marc home in 2015's
the Martian Mindy Park wasn't her last
nerdy role from 2014 to 2017 she played
programmer Cameron on AMC's halt and
catch fire she achieved even more small
screen exposure when she starred
alongside Gugu mbatha-raw in San
Junipero hailed by many as the finest
episode of Black Mirror if you're
excited for terminator dark fate it may
have already caught another long-awaited
science fiction sequel dealing with
complex questions about artificial
intelligence that brings us to one of
McKenzie Davis's most prominent roles to
date Mary yet a replicant freedom
fighter in Blade Runner 2049 Terminator
dark fate introduces us to Rev 9 an
advanced Terminator model played by
Gabriel Luna who you should definitely
recognize if you're a Marvel TV fan Luna
appeared in the fourth season of
Marvel's agents of shield as Robbie
Reyes aka the supernatural vigilante
Ghost Rider over his season-long Ark
Reyes having been granted the power of
the spirit of vengeance after getting
murdered by a street gang helps shield
tackle a few supernatural threats before
exiting the show at the season 4 finale
before playing Ghost Rider Luna starred
and ABC's short-lived crime procedural
wicked City as Detective Paco Contreras
fans of the El Rey Network may also
recognize him as Tony Bravo the soccer
star who doubles as a CIA operative in
Matador he appeared in 2011's dark
comedy Bernie the real-life story of a
mortician who befriends and later
murders an eccentric millionaire and
starred alongside Johnny Simmons and
clifton collins jr. in the 2016 thriller
trans-pecos the story of Border Patrol
agents embroiled in a conflict against a
drug cartel the woman who Grace and
Sarah Connor are wrists
everything to protect is Dani Ramos Dani
is played by Natalia Reyes a Colombian
actress whose fame has yet to find a
sure foothold with American audiences
but whose talents have already made her
a star in her native country Reyes is
perhaps best known for her starring role
in the Colombian telenovela lady love
and adore Adair OSIS the fascinating and
tragic true story of lady maria cabarrus
a famous Colombian actress who was
sentenced to 26 years in prison for
ordering the murder of a taxi cab driver
more recently Reyes starred in the
critically hailed crime epic birds of
passage which gained her much more
international attention including in the
States we hope Arnold Schwarzenegger
looks familiar
if he doesn't Hey we're not judging but
it's just kind of a mystery why you're
interested in Terminator dark fade at
all maybe you thought it was a really
hardcore pest control service but we
don't know Schwarzenegger first film was
a starring role in 1970s Hercules in New
York his prominence as the action hero
of the 80s began with 1984 s Conan the
Barbarian in which he played the savage
warrior of Robert E Howard's fiction
that same year he starred as the
ruthless cyborg hunting Sarah Connor in
James Cameron's The Terminator
truly cementing his status as a
pop-culture icon I'll be back ironically
while the first Terminator film did so
much for his career he didn't play bad
guys much after that throughout the 80s
and 90s he battled mercenaries in
commando hunted a monster in the
predator when a deadly game show in the
running man got his ass to Mars and
Total Recall and failed to keep the wool
over Jamie Lee Curtis eyes and True Lies
through it all he made the delivery of
violent yet corny one-liners into an art
all its own as he grew in Fame he was
successful in a couple of memorable
comedies as well namely 1988 twins and
1990s Kindergarten Cop
more recently Schwarzenegger has been a
regular fixture in the Expendables
franchise and turned a surprisingly
subtle performance in 2015's Loki's
zombie drama Maggie
oh yeah and between 2003 and 2011 he was
busy being the 38th Governor of
California check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one